we are heartbroken
we are grieving
[Music]
we are in pain we are frustrated we are
angry we are outraged we're scared
we're scared for our friends and family
i think we're feeling
despair uh
and i think we're questioning our place
in this country
many people sacrificed everything they
have to to come here because they
they believe that this is a place for
kind courageous strong
and fair people i think we are
wildly misunderstood we don't feel seen
the only thing that all
asian americans have in common in this
country
is that they have experienced racism i
felt
extremely hurt and angry
and at the same time i felt inspired to
finally
stand up and say no that's not right
how would i describe asian americans
that i know
[Music]
they are everything i am chinese
american i'm taiwanese american
i am a naturalized japanese-american i'm
indian american i am a chinese filipina
american
i'm a proud korean american we are
hilarious we are
generous kind multiracial
we are resilient we are
courageous heroic we are creative
we have grand dreams empathetic
open-minded
the asian-americans i know um are
outspoken are expressive
are very lazy
i'm talking about myself we're brilliant
we are wild we're crazy we are
phenomenal emotional organized
clumsy we're just like everyone else i'm
an animator illustrator and director
i'm a show creator executive producer
i'm a
playwright and screenwriter i'm an
animation producer
i am a comedian an actor and activist
i'm a composer songwriter i'm an actor
comedian
writer producer we are american we are
american we are american we are american
what draws me to animation is really
that your only limitations are your
imagination it almost takes things like
race
class gender and it
transcends those ideas i think the
special thing about animation
is it's the first real content you see
in your life as a child it has a huge
impact
if a really spoke to your heart she was
voiced by me
if you had cried on the opening minutes
of the movie up
that was me if watching clouds brought
your family closer
around the holidays that was produced by
me if you
thought that stand up comedy by asian
americans
was amazing well guess who started it
that was me
if you thought china was fierce and
beautiful and fabulous
that was voiced by me if you loved the
movie how to train your dragon 2
i was a storyboard artist on that if you
like chief benja
and ryan the last dragon and you love
the idea of unity
that was me if you've seen the movie
kubo and the two strings
kubo was my nickname growing up that
character
is mean if you love
toy story one or two or three i worked
on all three of them then you love me
can you imagine writing eight shows that
made it to broadway
that was me if you fell in love with
over the moon
that was produced by us and i co-wrote
the ultra luminary songs
if you loved exploring the high seas
with moana
i was a part of making that if you love
watching hotel transylvania with your
family
i was a storyboard artist on that did
you laugh till you cried watching snl
i helped create that remember when poe
finally met his dad
if you enjoyed kofu panna two or three i
directed those if watching goby
made you laugh sometimes it causes me to
get a little tongue-tied
that was me if you were in love with or
had a crush on or lusted after captain
dichang in
disney's mulan guess what that was me
i did that that was me oh that me
i wrote that i made that that that was
me
that was me that was me we did that that
was all of us
together
i'm fighting for my aunties my cousins
my family everyone who feels like home
to me
i'm fighting for new voices
i'm fighting for young people
who are going to be the next generation
of artists
and leaders and culture makers i wish
for a world
of tolerance empathy compassion
i would love to see a time where every
10 year old child can watch tv
and no matter who the cast is made up of
they don't think twice about who's not
included
because everyone is for the future i
wish to be
fearless i wish that all people were
less
afraid because of course it's fear that
causes people to mistreat each other we
have so many problems
but we can change that we can change
everything
my call to action would be speak up
even if your voice shakes speak up be
loud
take up space be yourself be proud
of who you are you can sign up for
bystander intervention training
so you can support local small asian
businesses in your area or not in your
area be active
be responsible be compassionate let's
educate ourselves about asian american
history
never allow yourself to be silenced or
invisibilized
you belong here know that you're not
alone
please tell your stories let people know
who
we are and what our lives are really
like if you want the violence to stop
then you have to speak
up if you want the racist
representations of asians to stop
on screen then you have to speak up stop
asian hate
stop asian stop stop stop stop stop stop
[Music]
it's time to truly be
proud of who we are and shout it from
the rooftops
and open our hearts and our lives to
everyone
for everyone to see
you